spring has come early to this part of
north london so what better time for the
leader of the opposition to set out his
plans to regenerate the labour party
although kirsten has been in the thick
of it through brexit and now as party
leader
it's easy to forget that he is
comparatively new to politics
i was elected here in 2015 um
which was uh what five and a half years
ago um
and uh it feels a lot longer now but
actually yeah of course it is only five
and a half years what five and a half
years it's been as well what five and a
half years
kiya that's the one
yeah how are you doing how are you yeah
not too bad you're fair enough all right
and now he faces the biggest challenge
of all to win back the voters
thank you so much great nice to see you
take care thank you
party good fantastic that's good to hear
but he's operating in a landscape
transformed by the kovid-19 pandemic
the prime minister is updating the
vaccine target so that every adult
should have their first dose by the end
of july you must
welcome the news absolutely welcome this
news and i think the whole country will
welcome
the news the vaccine is the light at the
end of the tunnel and
all credit to those on the front line
who've been rolling this out the nhs
have done a fantastic
job i've been to a number of vaccine
centers and it's it's very very
uplifting and i think
everybody wants to support this so this
is very welcome
so monday the prime minister is going to
start outlining
the road map out of lockdown what
restrictions do you want to see lifted
and when
well what i want to see from the prime
minister is
um a cautious careful exit from lockdown
we all want this to be the last lockdown
so we've got to come out of it in a
measured way
but make sure that in know we're not
back where we started in a number of
weeks or months
so roll out slowly carefully
follow the science i would say the prime
minister published the science i think
that will give great confidence to what
he has to say
on monday when he puts out the road map
i think the other thing is
recognize that because there will be
ongoing restrictions of some sort
businesses desperately need more support
it's one of the reasons we've said
that the business rate relief should go
on for another six months vat
should be reduced in key areas such as
hospitality so
careful cautious follow the science and
make sure the support is there for
business they've got this far
they need to survive beyond the net set
of restrictions
of course one of the really big
decisions is around schools yeah the
government said its ambition is to open
all schools to all pupils on the 8th of
march teaching unions have said that
they are worried about that they prefer
a more staggered approach
which side is right ideally i'd like to
see all schools back open on the 8th of
march
and all children back in schools on the
8th of march i've been
worried through the pandemic a number of
people have about the impact of being
out of school has on
particularly vulnerable children and the
attainment gap is getting bigger so
ideally the 8th of march we'll have to
see
obviously where the data is see where
the science is but that's what we should
be working towards
if that means more testing if that means
nightingale classrooms
if it means other measures let's do that
because i want to get our kids back into
school
so the teaching unions who are saying
that it should be staggered it should be
different year groups
you don't support that ideally we want
to see all those children back on the
8th of march that's what the prime
minister said would happen
we're going to have to go carefully of
course we are we're going to look at the
detail
and the data as we go into those weeks
just before the 8th of march see where
we are
on the infection rates but you know i've
always been concerned about the impact
on children being out of school but
you know actually i think if we do this
together we can get through this
another um big issue some people talk
about is this idea of vaccine passports
the idea that you would need a passport
to go into a pub or into a restaurant is
that something that you think is a good
idea
well i think it depends and it's a very
very difficult issue let me be
absolutely clear about that and i
i think people giving yes no answers is
a risky business here
i think internationally it's probably
inevitable that some sort of vaccine
passport
is going to come into being you already
see that in some countries
for yellow fever and other infections so
i think internationally
it's almost inevitable i think the
collecting of the data is important so
we need one place where the data is
stored you know who's been vaccinated
how can you access those
records etc vaccine passports within the
uk i think is something we need a
national debate about it is
very difficult to see how it would work
but
you know let's tread very very carefully
on this where are your
instincts though what what's your
instinct well i'd be very worried
for example if we got to a situation
where it was suggested that people would
lose their job
if they hadn't had a vaccine on the
other hand i can of course see the
concerns people have about their own
safety
perhaps in their home in their teams at
work etc
and that's why i really think on this
one we need a proper national debate
let's not pretend
there's an easy yes no answer because
there isn't one now you were
elected leader last april over just
dominated
absolutely everything since and there
has been some criticism
that you haven't shown enough leadership
on coverage you haven't taken enough
risks call for things before they were
inevitable i'm thinking about people
like tony blair for example who
called first for the spacing between the
doses rory stewart who
at the beginning of last year was
calling for lockdowns before other
people
do you think there's been a tendency for
you only to really call for things once
they're already gonna happen
well the approach i took was the
approach i set out on the very first day
i became leader of labour party
and that was to recognize that this is a
pandemic a global pandemic with huge
challenges
and i said what we would do is we would
support the government where we thought
they were doing the right thing
and challenge them where we thought they
were wrong so for example on the
lockdowns on the restrictions
we have supported the government voted
with the government on those lockdowns
and that was the right thing to do and i
think the public expected us to do that
and then we've challenged them where
they're wrong actually if you look at
probably my two biggest challenges to
the government
the first was in the autumn when i said
having looked at the
medical advice we need to go into a
circuit break or a lockdown
and it wasn't just before the government
did it on the contrary
boris johnson scoffed at the idea said
there was no way he
was still three weeks before sage
recommended it they weren't exactly
leading the debate when people were
already calling for it
the minutes were published three months
three weeks after they were written
as soon as we saw them we called for it
but the arguments that
um somehow the government was about to
do it the prime minister
scoffed at me and said he's not going to
go into a lockdown three weeks later he
did it
we had the same thing at christmas when
i stood up and challenged the prime
minister and said look this christmas
mixing
is heading for trouble he stood the
dispatch box and said to me you want to
cancel christmas i'm not going to do it
a few days later he u-turns so the idea
that we've only called for things just
before the government's about to do it
actually i don't think in fairness is
bear is borne out by
uh the examples that i've just given
okay a really simple question for you
um matt hancock has been found to have
acted unlawfully
over not publishing these covered
contracts should he resign
i don't want to call for him to resign
i do think he's wrong about the
contracts there's been a lot of problems
with the contracts on transparency
on who the contracts have gone to and
there's been a lot of wasted money and i
think that is a real cause for concern
but at the moment at this stage of the
pandemic
i want all government ministers working
really hard
to get us through this because you know
whatever political differences what the
public know is
this needs to succeed the vaccine rolled
out needs to succeed
and i think in those circumstances what
i'd say to matt hancock is
you need to you know go further on the
vaccine go faster on the vaccine you
need to have a road map on monday from
the prime minister
but i think at this stage going for
people to resign is not what the public
really want to see
now i'm keen to throw forwards because
some of the big challenges
are going to be about rebuilding the
economy we're rebuilding the country
post at the current crisis uh you course
gave a big speech this week
what should a post cover economy look
like
well we're getting to a real fork in the
road
um the vaccine i think gives us that
hope that we will come out of this and
then the question the critical question
which i think will define you know the
next general election probably the next
10 years is
do we when we come out of this want to
go back to where we started
and repair what we had go back and i say
no because what we had before this was
an economy which was
unequal and insecure and we've had 10
years of austerity and it's caused
such inequality and such insecurity for
people in the economy
so we take a different path which is to
go forward to a different and better
future where
we have a government an active
government working with business
to tackle inequality not only because
it's a wrong in itself
but because inequality doesn't work for
a good economy that's
going to be the big political choice you
say coming up and i'm very clear which
direction labor will go on
have you been a bit disingenuous here
though because you said that the
government wants to go back they want to
build back but you've
quite conveniently missed out the better
bit didn't you build back better
which is very different meaning well if
the government
is prepared to say that they recognize
that after 10 years of a conservative
government the
model we had going in but they do they
say that they don't want austerity they
don't want to return to austerity they
recognize the model was
um unjust insecure and unequal
then let me hear the prime minister say
that that is the result of the first
of the 10 years we've had of
conservative government because that is
their
track record and if you look at the
chancellor true it is
true it is that um they've put in
measures
and the status had to be active in the
last 10 months or so
but that's necessity that's not a values
judgment
and what the child the chancellor's
instinct is
how quickly can i extricate myself from
this
withdraw those measures not how long do
they need to be in for
and the other bit of evidence i just
throw in here is that whatever the prime
minister says about the state and the
future and leveling up
just look at some of the decisions in
the last few months
the refusal to keep the uplift in
universal credit
council tax rises for people across the
country
and a pay for is for police officers and
those on the front line
these are not the hallmarks of a
government that is serious
about dealing with inequality and the
insecurity that is baked into our
economy but if you
if you look at the decisions they made
over the last year you have to look at
the furlough scheme as well
you can't just say ignore the furlough
scheme that huge
government intervention that we saw but
just look at these bits
look at them on the record the last year
or you don't i'm not suggesting we
ignore that of course they've taken
measures um
we've supported those measures we think
they should have gone further in various
places but that's to one side
but they've done that for necessity the
idea that this is some conversion from
the
uh conservative party a way that you can
conveniently forget the last 10 years
they've
converted to social democracy i think is
completely
wrong no i'm keen to find out more about
you about what you believe in and the
kind of country that you want to build
so early this month the labour
strategy document was linked to the
guardian and they talked to focus groups
who
said that people are confused about what
we stand for and what our purpose is
and they also think that you need to
stop sitting on the fence so i want to
find out
a bit more about the real care stamina
you know banning the kind of
generalities that no one would disagree
with like fairness
what is it that you really stand for a
driving determination
to root out inequality and insecurity in
our country and our society in an
economy
and to build a better future for britain
yes i'm patriotic that was one of the
issues that was in this
report that was lee of course i'm
patriotic
i want to be prime minister of this
country because i want this country to
be even better than it is
now actually the whole labour movement
is very patriotic we
we are in politics to change our country
for the better
you can't be more patriotic than that
and i'm very very comfortable with it
i just wonder if it does sound quite
general still though doesn't it that you
want to build a better country that you
want to stop inequality i mean no one
would really disagree with that
would they well i don't think it's
general to say that
the economic model that we've had for a
decade
has completely failed and we need to
sweep it away and bring in something
where you have an active
government tackling inequality tackling
insecurity
and working actively with business as a
business partnership
going forward and the the
forward-looking businesses
know that the days of deregulation the
days when you don't need to worry about
the climate
uh emergency are over and actually
there's a real opportunity there
to to shape a better britain for the
next generation
that is what pulses through my veins
that's what i want
to achieve and if we can take the labor
party from where it is now to where we
need to be to win the next general
election
that is what we'll do okay i'm keen to
talk about a few specifics now just to
get a bit of a sense about where you
start stand on some of these key issues
so immigration in the labour leadership
you promise to defend free movement as
we leave the eu you've now dropped that
pledge
well we've left the eu and free um
movement is gone
is the reality of the situation and
we'll dave we'll face a different
situation in 2024 because we have left
free movement has gone would you like to
have free movement well we're going to
have to have a fair and humane
immigration system and we will set out
what that is in 2024 but
uh free movement is gone and and you
can't flick a switch
uh on this free movement depended on
membership of the
eu depending on membership of the single
market and we're at a different place
now how about drugs do you think there's
a case for
decriminalizing cannabis possession i've
never subscribed to that
view when i was director of public
prosecutions
i prosecuted many many cases or my team
did
involving drugs and drug gangs and the
criminality that sits behind
and it causes huge um issues
to vulnerable people across the country
so i've never gone down that
route there were some initiatives in
some parts of the country where
cautions were given for low-level crimes
i think there may be something in that
but
in principle i've seen too too much of
the damage
that sits behind drugs um for me to go
down that route so the current policy
you think is
roughly right well it's roughly right of
course you know there's always room for
a grown-up debate about exactly how we
deal with these cases but
what sits behind drugs is the
criminality of the gangs
and you know if i look in my
own constituency at some of the issues
in relation to knife crime which is
blighting the lives of young people
sitting just behind that are county
lines and drug running and
that's the kind of impact it has on our
society
and how about um trans issues as well do
you think that trans women should
have access to women-only spaces such as
prisons for example or toilets or
refuges well look trans rights are human
rights and the trans community amongst
the most
abused and discriminated of any
community and we need to absolutely
understand that and have a grown-up
discussion about how we go forward
i don't think we're in the right place
on trans rights i think we should go
further than the current
legislation but what i don't want is
this
war that's going on at the moment by you
know two different groups
fighting each other in a way that we
can't make progress so you say you want
to go further
in what way well i think that if you
look at the legislation that's in place
the processes and procedures are
demeaning
and there's too many stories of how
demeaning it is that i've heard for
myself we must be able to do better than
that
i have of course um dealt uh when i was
director of public prosecutors with many
women who've been through
domestic abuse domestic violence etc and
i know
how precious some of the spaces are that
they need
um to be secure to be safe
and and therefore there are no easy
answers here and as i say just
just taking lumps out of each other
pretending there's a yes no answer for
everything i think he's wrong
now just before we finish uh lisa nandy
said in an interview
last month that joe biden is awoke guy
whose victory was a source of hope for
labour
are you awake guy well i am what i think
about president biden is the values that
drove him through his campaign and the
values that he's putting on show
as a president and i admire those values
i think it's a
shot in the arm for um for global
politics shot in the arm for politics
here
and i'm i'm a values-led person and i
think that
is what joe biden is and is that a
weight guy well look it's a values-led
person and um just banding of words
around don't help
i'm values driven i'm utterly determined
that we can do something to tackle
inequality to tackle insecurity
and that we can do that sooner when we
think if we pull together as a party
pulled together as a movement we
obviously lost very badly in december
2019. i am convinced and i'm fighting
every day a week month and year into
2024
that we can turn this around and bring a
labour government in in 2024 and make
the difference we need for our country
i mean some people would say though that
you know you say you can turn it around
but we've had
116 000 deaths related to covid
the worst economic hit since the great
frost in the early 1700s and yet you're
still behind in the polls well
look we're living through a terrible
pandemic
a year ago i was in the leadership race
to become the leader of labour party and
journalists were saying to me is the
labour party even
going to survive here so that was the
challenge put to be 12 months ago
now people are putting to me are you
going to form the next government
that tells you how far we've come did i
think this was a one year project that
we could turn around the worst losses
1935 and 12 months no i didn't
do i think competence is enough no i
don't do i think it's a four-year
journey
yes i do in the leadership election i
asked you
which former labour leader you'd compare
yourself to it's a question you're quite
familiar with so i'm going to ask
something that i think you probably
haven't been asked before
you're an arsenal fan what arsenal
player would you compare yourself to oh
every time i'm asked about my football
skills i say i'd like this that or the
other
and all the guys i play football they
text me straight away and say
in your head in your dreams so um i'm
just going to tell you that thierry omri
is my favorite artist but
who would you compare yourself to i'm a
midfield player in the middle of the
pitch
i like to think i'm a box to box player
which means across the whole pitch
but i now know that as this goes out
there will be plenty of people who've
played football
with me saying uh in your dreams kia
um you grew up in surrey how come you
are an arsenal fan well because
uh i've been a football fan all my life
arsenal was a team that i
first started supporting and now of
course they're my local team so i'm a
season ticket holder and i can walk from
my house
to arsenal takes about 25 minutes and
that is fantastic
thank you very much